the tokenizer pipeline
in this video we'll look at how a
tokenizer converts vertex to numbers
that a transformer model can make sense
of
like when we execute this code here is a
quick overview of what happens
inside the tokenizer object first
the text is split into tokens which are
words parts of words
or punctuation symbols then the
tokenizer adds potential special tokens
and converts each token to our unique
respective id
as defined by the tokenizer's vocabulary
as we'll see it doesn't quite happen in
this order but doing it like this
is better for understandings the first
step
is to split our input text into tokens
we use the tokenized method for this
to do that the tokenizer may first
perform some operations
like lowercasing all words then follow a
set of rules to split the result in
small
chunks of text most of the transformer
models uses a word organization
algorithm
which means that one given word can be
split in several tokens
like tokenize here look at the
tokenization algorithms video linked
below for more information
the hash prefix we see in front of eyes
is a convention used by board to
indicate this token
is not the beginning of the world other
tokenizers may use different convention
however
for instance albert organizers will add
a long underscore
in front of all the tokens that added
space before them
which is a convention shared by all
sentence-based tokenizers
the second step of the tokenization
pipeline is to map those tokens to their
respective ids
as defined by the vocabulary of the
tokenizer
this is why we need to download the file
when we instantiate a tokenizer with the
frompretrade method
we have to make sure we use the same
mapping as when the model was retrained
to do this we use the convert tokens to
ids method
you may have noticed that we don't have
the exact same results as in our first
slide
or not has this looked like a list of
random numbers anyway in which case
allow me to refresh from memory
where the number at the beginning and
another at the end but are missing
those are the special tokens the special
tokens are added by the proper model
method
which knows the indices of a token in
the vocabulary
and just adds the proper numbers in the
input ids list
you can look at the special tokens and
more generally at how the tokenizer has
changed your text
by using the decode method and the
outputs of the tokenizer object
as for the prefix for the beginning of
words part of words
both special tokens vary depending on
which tokenizer you are using
the bert organizer uses cls on set but
the robot tokenizer
uses html like on course s and slash
s now that you know how the tokenizer
works you can forget all those
intermediate methods
and only remember that you just have to
call it on your input texts
the output of the tokenizer don't just
contain the input id however
to learn what the attention mask is
check out the batch input together video
to learn about docker type ids look at
the process parts and sentences video
you